[Musik]
hey zusammen heute gibt's mikas cookies
meine ultra leckeren snacks cookies und
das ganze nach dem lgs prinzip haben da
hast du gut aufgepasst
das prinzip ist lecker einfach und
schnell es losgeht so wären jetzt alles
zusammen ganz einfach ohne
küchenmaschine heute mal könnt ihr
natürlich auch nutzen aber ich habe gar
nicht zeigt euch mal so ich hab hier
butter geschmolzen in der mikrowelle bei
geringer war zeit für ungefähr 360 watt
eine minute wenn ihre hörer die leute
dann platzt die butter auch das wollt
ihr nicht wie oft ist mir das passiert
haben sie du bist mein zeuge wie oft um
mein gott die butter ist abgekühlt dass
es super super wichtig jetzt kommt
nämlich brauner zucker dazu und ich
schreibe euch alle ganz genauen
mengenangaben in die wurst infobox
das versuche ich jetzt miteinander und
danach kommt schon das ei mit dazu
[Musik]
als nächstes mehr und backpulver dazu 7
und im ersten moment sieht so aus als
wäre das echt viel mehr aber das ist
richtig so das ist so eine masse ich
kann die er zeigen als beschreiben also
die glänzt so ein bisschen die ist dick
und dadurch dass ich jetzt eine größe m
benutzt hat muss ich jetzt auch keine
milch mehr hinzufügen kleiner tipp von
mir habt ihr eine große rest an und
schlug mich auch dazu geben aber das
werdet ihr merken und dadurch dass es
jetzt ist mikas cookies sind haben so
was sind die drei typischen
eigenschaften eines nutzers ja ja ja das
kamera und schokolade genau und daher
natürlich kommen erste rein bitte nehmt
da gesalzen nicht die ungesalzene nehmen
und wenn jedoch ungesalzene nimmt dann
auf jeden fall richtig schön diese als
dazu oder meersalz meine sind schon
gesalzen dann habe ich hier die erdnüsse
dann habe ich hier susanne
karamellbonbons und debug festen
schokoladen chance und die tram allen
hier die werde ich jetzt noch klein
hacken und dann habe ich da alles noch
mal unter
[Musik]
so schon fertig der teig das ging
superschnell und jetzt werde ich einen
tag trotz den iran nehmen dann könnt
euch nämlich sicher sein dass alle
cookies zeitgleich fertig werden weil
die halt immer die gleiche menge hat und
ich glaube auch nur sechs cookies auf
ein blech weil die gehen nach dem bug
noch auf ihr müsst jetzt auch nicht rein
drücken oder so die gehen ganz von
alleine noch die werden noch flach
zeichnung der ofen ist auch schon
vorgeheizt 190 grad ober unterhitze die
backzeit fahrrad ich euch gleich aber
noch und ich gebe obendrüber auch noch
von unseren drei toppings noch ein
bisschen was damit nämlich auch später
dann hübsch aussieht
[Musik]
leute ich sag's euch ganz ehrlich sieben
minuten maximal acht bloß nicht länger
ihr müsst euch vorstellen
der ofen ist ja vorgeheizt das ist ganz
wichtig und auf dem blech träumen sie
noch so ein bisschen nach zumindest von
unten weil das blech ja auch
dementsprechend heiß ist und ich
korrigiere und und und und und gibt nur
vier cookies auf ein blech weil es kann
schon schaut mal hier ist kann schon
passieren dass die aneinander kleben und
dann habe ich jetzt ein richtig coolen
tipp für euch hinter jetzt einfach eine
schüssel
diese ausnahme freeman und dann macht
ihr folgen muss da sieht hübsch aus muss
man jetzt mit dem auch noch guck mal
jetzt sieht er noch nicht so schön aus
kurz zum vergleich und auch als
wertvoller tipp der kuki war zehn
minuten drin und es würde tier
vielleicht man ja der ist gerade ist
schön goldbraun aber der ist schon zu
dunkel
also der wäre mir schon zu knusprig ich
finde cookies müssen schön weich sein
und wundert euch nicht wenn ihr die aus
dem ofen holt sind sie noch so dass ihr
euch zerbrechen wenn ihr die anheben
würde
lasst die kurz auf dem blech abkühlen
und dann werden sie nach dem abkühlen
auch fest ich immer meine schicke hebe
palette und dann habe ich das ganz
vorsichtig an ihr könnt auch ganz
vorsichtig anheben
und dann auf ein absperrgitter tun falls
ihr angst habt dass es euch unten auch
zu knusprig wird der rand darf nur ganz
leicht goldbraun sein und dann sind sie
fertig und ich fordere jetzt in hamm
daher auf das er rum kommt und mit mir
den test macht diese schönheit ein sehr
schön wieder so präsentieren würde so
hübsche probieren mal und bis natürlich
immer super super ehrlich wenn uns das
nicht schmeckt dann sagen wir das auch
mal sagen aber wirklich sagen wir jeder
ein- oder sagen wir durchbrechen
zusammen
[Gelächter]
das ist ja noch mal dies mal komm komm
ja ich habe schon lange kennen der schon
gesteckt weil das stück alles quatsch
bedeutung und wir probieren jetzt mal so
konsistenz die sind schon sehr früh
nämlich so ein bisschen
doch ich werde das spiel erwarten also
die konsistenz ist geil geil die ist
nicht eher trocken oder so
ich probier mal also ich würde sogar
noch geld also ist bei cookies ich werde
mir ja die schmecken hat ultra frisch
und selbst gebacken
das schmeckt einfach mit dem karamell
das schmeckt man schon richtig was los
ist auf jeden fall dass ich hätte ja
auch ist nicht ganz klein schneiden und
rein machen könnte aber ich fand es
irgendwie so coole und das tolle ist
wirklich über diesen cookies ihr habt
euch diese salz note die schoko note
dieses süß salzige ich lieb sondern ist
auch nicht zu salzig das ist er richtig
mit extrem aber jetzt kein snickers
erwischt also keine schoko und karamell
zusammen haben nicht wirklich aber wenn
man diese drei komponenten berichtet
auf jeden fall wird's auf jeden fall bei
dem jetzt weil mein stück jetzt noch ein
paar mehr renten kann ja wie schokolade
und karamell bin ich auch er hat sich
auch so was bist du ja auch so also ganz
genau geizt nicht mit den schultern aber
dies ist folge lautet ja also ganz auf
jeden fall nicht wisst ihr was ich ende
euch auch die mengenangaben so dass ihr
genug schokolade habe dass die genug
karamell und genug ereignisse habt finde
ich richtig geil das rezept gefällt mir
richtig gut
ich bin ganz ehrlich ist es ein
spontanes fit gewesen ich habe mir
überlegt nicht gas cookies ich will erst
mal das lied just orte man jetzt schon
so spät und ich hab heute machen wir
dann übermorgen
und da kommt sie auch ganz bald online
liefere so traurig rein ich kann mich
auch noch eins und dann wünsch euch ganz
viel spaß im nachbacken ich freue mich
über eure fotos macht geht nicht auf
instagram und da muss man sagen sehen
wir uns beim nächsten video
und der hand war ich nicht wirklich
glücklich
essen macht glücklich ein süßes sowieso
[Musik]